it's an ambitious plan to cut pollution
from traffic
britain's set to ban the sale of new
petrol and diesel vehicles by 2030
10 years earlier than originally
scheduled some hybrids will still be
allowed
but there'll be grants for electric cars
and funding for charging points
all part of a new 10-point plan aimed at
making sure the uk meets its commitment
to achieve net zero carbon emissions by
2050.
prime minister boris johnson is calling
it a green industrial revolution
the plan aims to create up to two
hundred and fifty thousand
highly skilled green jobs by twenty
thirty it includes a pledge to make
london the center of global green
finance
and involves mobilizing sixteen billion
dollars of government money
with the private sector providing up to
three times that amount
one highlight is a pledge to quadruple
offshore wind power by 2030
producing enough electricity to power
every uk home
as well as a big boost in hydrogen
production but the opposition labor
party says only a third of the program
is new money
pointing out countries such as germany
and france are investing tens of
billions of dollars
for this expert it's a small step in the
right direction
just a few weeks ago we identified that
the government was spending just a tenth
of what's needed
every year to meet net zero 33 billion
pounds
a year is what's needed every year over
this parliament what's been announced
today is welcome but it does fall
short from what we think is needed the
plan involves greater investment in new
nuclear power plants as part of the
non-carbon energy mix
it also includes funds to insulate homes
and public buildings responsible for
roughly a third of the uk's carbon
emissions
as well as tree planting programs and
new carbon capture initiatives
but there's nothing about something
environmental campaigners want to see
a frequent flyer levy we believe and
this was supported by the uk's climate
citizens
assembly that there should be higher
taxes for those people who fly more
so that the first the first flights are
comparatively cheap but they become
steadily more and more expensive
because we know actually that just
fifteen percent of people in the uk
take seventy percent of the flights the
government's promising to invest in
clean public transport and make cycling
an easier way to travel especially in
cities
the challenge now is what incentives are
needed to make a real difference
nadeem baba al jazeera london